it's before sunrise in Cedar Falls Iowa
as the state begins to stir some people
have work to do Tim woolston is
preparing for the biggest moment of his
week Sunday worship as musical director
he'll be taking to the stage and
performing to a crowd of hundreds he
still sometimes gets nervous there's
always something unexpected you know
that can happen whether that's actually
the spirit moving in the room or it's a
Satan the evil one trying to do
something against us and also it's just
there's different people in the room and
so sometimes I can get in a risk but I
also know that it's not about me and tim
is not alone two hours before the
service his bandmates join him for
rehearsal it's a professional operation
this is one of the largest evangelical
churches in the area and music is at the
heart of its services
as the congregation arrives the
pre-service chatter is all about the
caucuses most here will be supporting
Republican candidates we are
conservatives and we kind of look at the
whole picture and we are leaning toward
Marco Rubio at this point I really like
a lot of times the way ben Carson
expresses his faith and the things he
talks about the way he answers questions
is a a well thought-out person but drop
in on one of the church's past us and
you'll find not everyone fits the
conservative profile Jeff Mickey stays
out of politics but his 18 year old
daughter says she will support the left
wing Bernie Sanders gay people lesbian
people that's been a huge topic and
people judging them and trying to take
change them and stuff and that's not
what Christianity is about at least as I
see it is um it's acceptance and we need
to accept accept people for who they are
as for pastor Jeff himself he's just
worried that American politics have
become too inward-looking and driven by
fear so we're part of this global
community we can't just be focused on
ourselves we have to be focused on yet
how do we care for ourselves but then
how do we also be this blessing in this
world when you live by fear I think
that's a harder thing to accomplish
back at the church the emotional high
point of the service is a song about
overcoming fear
he rendered thousands of churches just
like it right across the country this is
the soaring sound of evangelical America
as Tim leaves the stage the spiritual
kick is still with him and as he thinks
about what America should be beyond 2016
his belief is his guide I just have a
great faith that God is in control of
this nation of our country of this world
and so I have great faith that he's
going to put the person in office that
he wants to be there whether I think
it's the right person or not I just have
a great faith that guy's going to do
that because I believe his almighty hand
is at work in this world it's a faith in
God that seems to echo America's faith
in democracy that when it comes down to
it America will make the right choice
this election year a choice that begins
today here in Iowa